Fabiano karana well he was about to be
pushed off a cliff but miraculously he
managed to spin his way out of it and
save the game Bobby we all saw you dead
- all right so you must have felt the
same way how did you manage to escape
yeah i blundered at some moment when I
played 97 I thought that he can't play a
5 because we're going to trial and then
as soon as he took on age of 6 I
realized that there's no G 4 and I can
resign there although already my
position is unpleasant and it has been
for quite a few moves which is strange
because I thought I have a very decent
position and then I mean not not here
but like in an early middle game I felt
like after I played 95 I have a very
decent position and then and I'm slowly
I became worse it's strange because and
what I understand about these positions
but shouldn't be in any trouble here but
it seems like all my moves are fine
maybe 97 is better but then I thought of
Queen f1 g4 works you won and I didn't
see comfortably yeah it feels like up my
position should be fine but slowly I'm
being pushed back and the endings are
unpleasant and I think he played quite
well up to a point and then he punished
my blunder I mean obviously I shouldn't
play 90 70 here I should maybe take on
g5 but it still remains very unpleasant
because I have no counter play and he's
just playing Knight g4 and h6 at some
point or even slowly he can you know
play I mean I just can't do anything so
it was my biggest worry I kept saying in
the broadcast what are you supposed to
do yeah it's there there are no easy mu
screw block so to defend this you have
to to basically play perfectly up until
the end of the game and I didn't with 97
obviously did you see the night yet idea
here already well after after after you
took on h6 I have to start calculating
some sort of chance to save the game I
mean because like Ken's act upon like by
King h7 or g6 they're a bunch of ways to
sack the home but I thought it's just
hopeless I mean
his night night of three he starts to
jump I thought that this would provide
pretty much no hope so at least I have
to okay I put my pieces in horrible
positions but at least I keep the pond
yeah and then I I felt like after page
seven personal f6 is probably winning
because I can't obviously at the g8
square now and of 9594 King Ajay Bishop
c5 is crushing and so I thought I have
to play Knight of five after r6 and here
there are a bunch of things which I
thought were bad one was rich he thought
that maybe this is not so clear g6
regret g1 maybe I'm I can keep the game
going with some tactics like Knight h4
rook one g4 Bishop h6 and and I can
still fight on for a bit but also Knight
f3
instead of roof g5 it was very strong I
guess right here seven just nice right
it's a photonic position so I was kind
of really pointy by 94 because at least
I can sort of keep the game going
although after Knight G it may be H
sixes is very strong just positional are
you trying to g h6 for cage five
everything it's not so easy to go for
this but I can't really move which is
the problem well we should point out
that right around this time we had
magnets in the confessional that you
obviously would not know about because
you were busy playing but we'll give you
a look at what he did when he went into
confessional because he actually didn't
say any words here you go just taking a
look as he closes the door and he did
this the door closed
which is a that's no simple kind of
shutting up the haters before the close
of the game what are your thoughts a
little bit of premature celebration in
his part yeah I guess he thought it was
already over oh it wasn't who is he you
going in the confessional I haven't gone
in this tournament so far I don't know I
just I don't want it whenever I have a
good position I don't really want to
jinx it and usually by the time I've had
a good position there hasn't been much
to talk about anyway maybe what's your
sense of relief drawing this game keeps
him in first place in the tournament
yeah considering the position I had this
was a really great result and it was
also great that nobody else won today so
I'm still the leader good job Thanks
that'd be just a quick question at the
very very very end where draw was agreed
we thought that you two had a chance to
make a claim of a three move repetition
you're just your thoughts at the very
end of the game what was going on no but
III didn't think it was a 3-fold because
we have had this 197 rookie 295 or v6
three times but one time the rook was on
I think g1 and one time the work was on
that form he included this rook f1 King
Jade in the middle I could be wrong but
that's what I thought
okay but it looks like it was the case
though yeah maybe didn't worry you that
he might change lines and go in 1987
okay look it's so so safe for black I
mean after nine h5i I don't see any
danger I assumed that he was also
worried that if he strands the knight on
a 7 and allows me to play with my long
he could also risk coloreds
I guess objectively drawn another one
but okay it's I mean there's no risk for
black here I don't think so you didn't
worry in this moment
no no I wasn't worried anymore
well thank you very much the good thing
about having a dead loss position is
that you no longer see ghosts and detron
positions yeah you're just a nice sense
of relief well done fabbi and good luck
with your last two games leading the
sync